I've gotten so weird that there's a part
of me now that wants me not to buy the
Jets more than by the Jets I've seen
this Evolution because I want to show
the world how pumped I'm gonna be for
Sarah McGee you've just celebrated your
47th birthday yes
more energy than ever shall I say but um
what if you as you really recollect on
your your childhood from from that
vantage point now what are the new
insights that you've attained about
yourself
probably the most recent one is like
this incredible need to be a superhero
you know I I really took the being the
oldest brother to Heart
you know it's funny my sister and I have
a joke that a lot of people don't know
that she exists because obviously me and
AJ were in business together and I talk
a lot about the Jets and that has AJ but
my relationship with my sister who's
three and a half years younger than me
may be one of the most profound
relationships I have
she undoubtedly was the first person
besides my mother that kind of cheered
for me
you know she looked up to me
my mother is incredibly close to her
brother and so she
spent a lot of time building that
relationship we're Incredibly Close I
feel much more kinship to her when I
think about my childhood than AJ because
I was 11 years older we didn't have the
same childhood we also moved when he was
three so all my childhood memories have
her in it
and I think as I've gotten in you know
last two three years I'm like oh I have
this like need to
be admired need you know everything that
works for me is when I feel like I'm
doing it for someone besides myself I'm
doing it to make my parents proud I'm
doing it to show my sister the right way
I'm doing it for my employees even the
way I got into better health and fitness
was I hired a babysitter but really what
I hired was someone to do it for Mike
and Jordan is who I want to make proud
today my scale being 175 versus 176 8
which it was two days earlier and Mike
texting me great job on the Travel day I
did it for him
and so as I'm getting older and so much
of the Gary Venus
I'm realizing is
I'm happy when I'm doing things that
make other people happy or
even at a higher level creating a
framework or a blueprint
that they can interpret into themselves
the thing I you know as I got older with
my sister a lot of things I talked about
was this is my DNA yours DNA is
different but like I just I want you to
be happy it's going to be different for
you know those kind of things and so
you know you know when I do things like
this I always go with the first thing
that came to my mind I think what's
obvious to me is
I've exhausted the conversation of
grinding and having to do it for myself
and learning how to be an entrepreneur
in the streets of New Jersey and and
recently last couple years I've talked
more about Candor when I wrote 12 and a
half I'm like this is My Kryptonite I'm
great at Candor in this format put me on
stage put me on a podcast give me 30
people listening to me I'm Candor King
managing Dustin one-on-one I just love
them too much like like even you know
even this interview like I went from a
company off site and like I got
emotional this morning speaking to the
35 global leaders and that was the first
time I got a I got emotional the way I
usually talk about my parents if I'm at
a Gala or something of that nature and
it hit me and I my observation was oh
these people are becoming my family I
talk about Brandon warnicki my best
friend and I tear up I talk about my
parents and my my siblings and I tear up
this was the first time I kind of teared
up for real for real deep deep deep deep
in a setting when I was talking about
those 35 leaders and it was a nice
feeling I'm like oh this is becoming
family and so you know I think I think
that Candor has been a weakness on a
one-to-one basis when it's emotional
that I've started talking about the
newest thing of this moment when you ask
me is what is it that makes me want to
be like this and to be very Frank
it's quite enjoyable
um and it makes me happy and even when I
don't deliver I'm happy at the attempt
of
and so I think I'll probably spend the
next half decade trying to finish this
thought and probably produce content
around it because I the thing I always
think about is
if I'm this happy if I lack the anxiety
that I see in 99.9 of people I have a
sense of responsibility to over
communicate in case a sentence on a
podcast triggers something for someone
and starts their journey to be happier I
don't know something more noble a human
can do than be on a quest to leave
collateral you know droppings along the
way that may help and will help others
so many directions I want to take that
in I'm going to go with um the first
comment you made and then I'll move on
to the second you said I have a desire
to be admired yes now when I reflect on
that I completely agree I think I lied
to myself for a couple of years and
thought that I was more noble than I was
but what I came to learn often from
doing this podcast was that some kind of
insecurity or some kind of Shame was
really the driving force at the heart of
me and as I sit here with athletes for
Israel adesanya the UFC champion whoever
it is you uncover these stories which at
a very young age the thing that might
have invalidated them when they were
younger is now the thing they're
striving to seek validation from as an
adult well it's funny I agree with that
and now I'm going to tell you why I walk
around Earth with gratitude and guilt
I everything you just said is one of my
biggest thesis in life that is 100 true
mine is slightly different
I got really fortunate it's like really
hard to talk about even without like
getting weird about it
I'm
my circumstances are you know I think
yes in some ways for example
the system
School took such a [ __ ] on me in the 80s
and 90s I've and you know this we've run
in similar circles I'm very good at
fighting the systems of Industries like
it's also why I see things like Netflix
you're gonna win Tesla you're gonna win
because I know they're fighting the
thing
and so I recognize it I've been a good
investor I've been a good operator and
I'm definitely a communicator college
right
I was at a talk yesterday I'm not
speaking that much but I like my dad
taught me you know keep your word so I
had a talk from pre-covid that got
canceled and then canceled and then I
got code like and so I I still did it
and so I did it uh yesterday and a
couple of moms came up to me and both of
them the way they talked to me about the
content I'm putting around College was
through love and admiration 12 years ago
those same exact moms were really angry
at me
you know and so when you see things you
know you you kind of challenge it and so
yes I think I absolutely the thing that
was an insecurity I get bad grades but
what was different for me is I didn't
believe them
this is this is where self-esteem is an
obsession of mine not delusion
right not delusion because that's what a
lot of modern parenting does you can do
anything Sally no you can't
Sally you are not athletic enough to be
in the WNBA
it wasn't that it was this weird balance
that my mom created between deep
confidence but accountability and truth
I remember trying to make an excuse for
striking out in a baseball game and
trying to use the sun in my eyes as an
excuse and my mom not letting me do it
very subtly
talk about childhood forming you like
this is why I implore everyone to
communicate their truth to their
children to the world through podcasts
through content like it's amazing to me
sentences change people's lives
right she didn't let me do it and I
became very accountable because of those
levels of parenting and realities and
that accountability led to so much
happiness but for me when the school
system was saying you're [ __ ] I didn't
believe them and so I watch a lot of
people being driven by hurt
and I can sense that I'm driven by love
I just sense it like for me it's just
like deep self-awareness that
understands how fortunate I've been like
so many things went my way the mom of
the century being able to leave the
Soviet Union in this little window in
the 70s 1917-19 in the 72 years that the
Soviet Union dictated people's life and
to remind everybody this this is
something most Americans and westerners
don't understand the Soviet Union was
like North Korea it wasn't like Iran
Iranians right now are able to leave
Iran and go to you know wherever their
passport is taken they can't go
everywhere but turkey takes their
passport Dubai takes their passport the
Soviet Union that my family grew up in
was North Korea you were not allowed to
leave
but this little event in 1970 of eight
Russians trying to hijack a plane to go
to Sweden to escape created a global
story that led to pressure on Russia
where Spain and Israel and America
teamed up and had this little moment
where Russia had spent too much money on
their weapons of war and were starting
to run out of resources and conform to
their anti-Semitism and decided to take
money from the U.S and Israel in
exchange for a couple of hundred
thousand people and I'm one of those
people and I born with insane levels of
Entrepreneurship and Gift of Gab and
offense get to go from the worst place
on Earth at the time and for someone
like me in 1978 to the best place on
Earth
[ __ ] and then getting all love but not
delusion and so by 10 being in the grit
of like studio apartment with tons of
family members and queen like all [ __ ]
but being 10 years old and having little
but being happy as [ __ ] and being loved
insane and now a 10 year old me realizes
that money has no impact on happiness I
was built to win
I was built to win and so I agree with
you I see it in so many of my friends I
always say the two ways to build
something insane is deep deep insecurity
turned into fuel or deep deep levels of
confidence turned into fuel
on that point of confidence you said
your mother gave you your confidence yes
earlier on you said you she gave you
your sense of sort of
self-responsibility yes but I've also
heard you say that she's responsible for
your confidence and then another thing
the market
so yes my mother and so a lot of people
are listening right now and they had
positive reinforcement there's two
things to watch out for for everybody
who's listening parents or youngsters or
just try to get everyone listening and I
by the way this is a good time to say
this
I consume a lot of
content meaning I consume no content I
consume how people are consuming content
I just want to give you some roses
and really The Listener on the other
side I've really enjoyed
and this is very lightweight this is a
hot take it's not like I've done a major
homework on this but I feel like you
have a very thoughtful audience I really
like what's going on with you and your
audience it's and it's really both of
you right it's not just you it's who
self selects to listen to your guests
and you're doing a great job casting and
all that but there's something nice
going on here so keep going and everyone
who's listening Kudos on you for
understanding there's value here in a
world of unlimited content here's the
two back to like kind of the respect
they have I told I told you Dustin I
said hey pay attention today I'm going
to be a little bit sharper it's out of
my admiration
here are the two things I want to go
extra level to watch out for in
confidence building too many people go
too far and they go into that eighth
place trophy delusional place and then
kids don't believe you I'm gonna be very
transparent I've already sensed that
with one of my children where they're
calling my bluff on it I'm like [ __ ]
it's true
like you're I played AJ much harder in
every sport than I'm playing Xander
that's the facts and so I'm already
adjusting my damn self Xander's your
child yes
so so one it's don't let it be
delusional the whole you can be anything
you can do anything you want you can be
anything you want you just might not be
the best at it or great at it
you can be a musician it doesn't mean
that you're going to be a financially
successful enough musician to pay for
your household or if you want to be you
can you're just gonna have to live
humbly and live your passion which I
think is going to be the conversation in
100 years I believe the evolution of you
and I and a lot of people listening is a
lot more people making sixty one
thousand dollars a year doing exactly
what has them on fire and living and
living this is a big part and living
within the means of that 61 000 but
that's a different conversation for a
different day so number one watch out
for delusion number two you can't be the
only source of positive reinforcement
had I never gone outside and my mother
did everything she did I don't think I
am who I am the other part that made me
was ringing doorbells and having 81
people say no kid I don't want you to
wash my car and having six of them say
yes kid I do want you to wash my car for
five dollars
I think what also made me was standing
on a lemonade stand
for months in my life you know two days
here three days here five days here
months of my life from six to thirteen
and watching 99.9 of the cars drive by
my stand and not react to my Great Signs
and not stop and buy my lemonade
I think what made me was a hundred out
of 105 people said no to shoveling snow
what made me was I had a baseball card
table and I watched a hundred people
walk by and not want to buy anything
from me even though I had good stickers
and good cards and one the market made
me all those no's became enjoyable
it's the yes that acts as the evidence
though so it's the it's the person
coming along in the 100 buying the
lemonade that makes uh young Gary or a
young me go do you know what I can sell
lemonade 100 and I was I've thought a
lot of over the years because the more I
speak on stage or the more I my brand
has grown I get the same question over
and over again which seems to be at the
very base level of everything I do which
is how does one build confidence you've
talked about your mum's sort of
subjective evidence that you are great
and then you've talked about the
evidence from the 1 in 100 buying
lemonade I came to this hypothesis that
um our self-belief like all our beliefs
is just
um based on false or correct subjective
evidence we have about ourselves so if
that is true if if beliefs or beliefs
are just evidence
um
what's your view on how someone can
build that self-confidence they're
listening to this now how do they go get
that evidence and do you agree with that
thesis yeah I like a lot of that thesis
I also think one of the things to point
out that might help a lot of people is
my mom
also create a positive reinforcement for
me on the right things when I think back
to what she positively reinforced
it was not when I get the occasional B
in history as a dnf student which would
be logical this is the first time I've
ever saying this publicly it's first
time I had a clear thought on it it
would be logical
for a mother who really she she knew how
smart I was she was borderline pissed
she's like can't you get seized to
appease me you're so capable I'm like
these and F's why she didn't positively
reinforce the bees I got in history
which was the one class I paid attention
to uh is actually a very interesting
insight
she didn't reaffirm a subjective machine
that wasn't billed for me what she
reaffirmed and built confidence in me
was how nice I was to everyone
when I think of my 47 year old self I am
the byproduct of two energies I'm a
successful entrepreneur which is what
the world taught me
and for the people that know they know
like especially the people that really
know they know how nice I am
like you know this you've been on you
know a lot more about me and subtle
little like what I love about you is
you're smart so I know I can say this
you know yeah I know yeah yeah right and
we've had lots of dealings over this
year right yeah in every subtle way yeah
in every subtle way we've theoretically
competed there's been moments where I
could or couldn't come like what I love
about this is you know and I've always
said that when I go into the grave so
many people are going to know me that as
long as the people that actually know me
feel what I want them to feel I ca you
know there are people who today don't
think I'm a great dude and it's off of
One Clip that somebody wanted to use me
to do a split screen to build themselves
up because they're in the business of
tearing people down to build their
building
and that doesn't bother me actually it's
one of like I actually have incredible
compassion for that person has it ever
hurt no so I'm going to tell you
something so when I became a dragon on
BBC's Dragon's Den I I was exposed to a
new level of public criticism and
misunderstandings of often intentional
misunderstanding so anything you say or
do
um art you know articles and different
sort of sides of the political Spectrum
who maybe hate entrepreneurship at times
sure doing pieces on me and then the
backlash and then other like real sort
of takedown efforts yes and there was
days where even my walls of like
resilience and toughness something kept
me up at night has that ever happened
for you where yeah we're all human being
I'm not a robot yeah it's that it's so
not sustained
tell me about a time when that happened
you don't have to give me the details
I'll tell you yeah there was a kid who
wrote a medium piece about me being the
face of hustle porn which to this day
lingers
and it was a medium article I was on a
plane I landed and it was just all this
chaos and there was a lot of things that
weren't true
like me I didn't inherit my dad's liquor
store I built my dad's store for him
there were some things that really like
trigger me that one always hurts because
I think I did one of the most noble acts
a human with Talent can do I knew at 17
that I was a [ __ ] guy
and I decided consciously
that I loved my parents so much that I
was going to dedicate a decade of my
youth Prime [ __ ] years
Pro 20 to 30 is [ __ ] you got time you
got energy you got I gave 10 of my
greatest years they're not my wisdom
years but they're my [ __ ] [ __ ]
years and I gave them gave them to my
parents
never made over a hundred twenty
thousand a year built a business from 3
to 65 million left with nothing started
vaynermedia in Mike Lazaro's conference
room at buddy media at 34 years old
because I had no [ __ ] money
I'm proud of that so when you can
imagine when somebody writes a hit piece
and says you can't listen to this guy he
inherited
his dad's liquor store that hurts when
you say hurts what are the symptoms of
that hurt for you oh you're gonna love
this because this is why it's not
sustainable I'm
I'm neutral
at all times
Gary you're the goat thank you Gary
you're [ __ ] I understand
why does it hurt I know that there is
millions of 15 to 25 year olds 30 to 60
year olds 61 to 90 year olds right now
who've decided not to consume my message
because one person who's hurting decided
to build themselves up by targeting me
because of the platform I'm on and that
disappoints me more than anything as
someone who is deeply deeply deeply
driven by leaving the impact at the
highest levels that he is capable of out
of the guilt and gratitude of winning
the DNA and environment game the
elimination of opportunity to help make
the world more about love
in lieu of someone reinforcing their
beliefs of living the world of dark and
hate is crushing for me philosophically
but the reason it's not sustained Steve
is my number one fan on Earth outside of
my family whoever that is Sally Pants
McGee and my number one person that
hates me the most thinks that the whole
thing is the worst can't wait till I die
I equally feel the same about it zero
on that day you landed from that plane
you see the no Twitter or whatever's
blowing up and all these people are
saying those things if I was sat next to
you yes what would I have of what would
I have observed uh hey this is too big
to not address in a world where 99.9
things I won't address
I want to at least create clarity
because it's gone too viral in a world
that I admire the readers of medium are
my contemporaries my friends people I
admire
and so I just didn't want six or seven
things that weren't true to be the
foundation of a hypothesis especially
when you go read crush it which is my
coming out moment it doesn't talk about
making money and buying a yacht when it
talks about working hard at night it was
under the context of the 2008 recession
people losing their jobs and me saying
hey I don't know if you know this but
the internet's getting mature and if you
go on YouTube and Twitter you might be
able to fix this shortcoming you have
and yes I understand that some of you
are also equally it's not just about
getting a new job or getting a job it's
also oh my God because this was this was
insane to me because I was just coming
out to the world now I was like in My
Little Wine Library bubble I'm like
people don't like their jobs like that
was like I loved it so much even if I
was doing it for my I loved it so much
that I was taken aback by that I was
like well if you don't like being an
accountant and you love Star Trek start
making Star Trek video I mean it's
insane what Tick Tock and Instagram and
YouTube have created you go read crush
it which I wrote in 2008 it's insane how
much of that became true even to me you
know why I'm asking I think I'm asking
this question and I please assisting on
this topic is because I've always seen
the way that you've publicly responded
in those moments and it's always been
with an unbelievable level of gratitude
and empathy and so I as someone who's
been on the receiving end of it it's
hard it's hard so it's just it's just
you know I'm sorry finished I was gonna
say so I've always wondered from afar
yeah someone who's been on the receiving
end of it what goes on as the the first
you know like the first reaction we have
to these things where you're like yeah I
mean the first hundred honestly the
first hundredth of a second reaction is
actually a very weird blend of
you'll see and I can't wait to be
gracious when you come to apologize
and I've I've had moments like that
where the thing the story whatever will
just stay on my mind and it will rattle
over and it might rattle over for like
six seven hours eight hours it might
rattle over at night time that night
might even rattle over the next morning
mate
does that happen to you too
it's very rare for it to be able to get
to the second day that next morning very
rare I just go deep into the [ __ ]
Gary Cave of okay this person I admire
just took a [ __ ] on me this this
influencer decided to [ __ ] on me
and I'm not talking about the comedians
who I love the comedian stuff is like
awesome because I'm like like and I just
did Dylan's podcast and I said it I'm
like that's that I'm like humbled by
like actual good comedians forget about
the people that impersonate me and have
built not their careers because they
impersonate others but like a couple of
these characters have really benefited
from impersonating me and that means so
much to me that I brought V con was my
crowning event and the first people that
hit stage were impersonators of me
there's no bigger cosine I can give to
like that feels amazing that somebody's
winning the thought that somebody's
winning in their comedic career because
they popped by impersonating me that's
like the most humbling feeling of all
time
not that not when people take shots at
me and like hyperbolize what I'm saying
for a laugh I'm I'm flattered by it I'm
talking about people that really like
[ __ ] this dude he's bad and and it's so
bad how they do it it's so very out of
context and things that nature
I just
I it just doesn't register I what you
know I if I'm hurt by midnight as I
close my eyes and then the first thing I
do when I close those eyes and the first
thing I do when I open those eyes I say
to myself okay
the world all eight billion people have
decided to go on social media and say
actually I'm a piece of [ __ ]
is that better or worse than my parents
dying in a car crash right now on the
way to the airport
I'd much rather have all 8 billion
people go on social media right now and
say I suck
then that to happen thus
I can't be upset about this in a real
way that's bigger problems there's
bigger problems
you referenced something earlier you
said wisdom years I found that really
really compelling because you reference
you know I think you said 20 to 30. I'm
now 30. just turned 30. so I guess I'm
in my wisdom years one of the things I
think this one's the in-between the time
in the 30s like right like just [ __ ]
go ham
um and for everybody listening this is
the years to taste a lot of [ __ ] make a
lot of mistakes have fun try different
things
like everything eat it all go to the go
to the you know
the
salad bar and try every single thing
that's in there 30 to 40 is the
refinement of 20 to 30.
especially if you really go at it you're
like okay I remember like 30 30s when
[ __ ] started popping for me February
21st 2006 is my first episode of Wine
Library TV
so I'm 30. I just turned 30. and that is
clear I mean the fact that within
December within three months of my 30th
birthday the very clear public data very
clear indication of the shift in my
career happened three months so that was
interesting and I think those are when I
think of 30 to 40 I refined a lot of
things that felt natural 20 to 30. I
refined my craft I started to get to
know myself better when I think about 40
to 47 I'm like that's an evolution of 30
to 40. I'm still refining I'm still
doing but I'm starting to get into a
thought of like okay
I like have real grasp on things I can
do some real damage like I'm scared in
the most positive way of what I'm gonna
accomplish selfish selfish and
selflessly from 50 to 60. scared I think
it's going to be banana [ __ ] I think
everything that is me right now is minor
leagues compared to what I'm gonna do 50
to 60 because I now have the context of
40 to 50 which is a more polished
version of the refinement of 30 40 and
so for me 50 to 60 feels like insanity
and then when I look at my 60 to 70 year
old business friends I'm like [ __ ] I get
an entire another decade after that
decade of doing it at a hundred and then
I start debating what happens at 70
right then I'm like 70 to 80 is still a
very clear decade for a certain very
small group to continue to go ham and go
[ __ ] insane I'm curious where I'll be
I notice 70 I'll be exactly the same way
I am right now it's inconceivable I'm
not
um those 23 years are pretty clear to me
they're going to look like the last 23
years
70 to 80 becomes an interesting debate
will I take any foot off the pedal will
I go to a different place I often
fantasize of like going into like a cave
in Peru and whoever wants to find me can
come and we get 30 minutes and I just do
that for the next 30 years of my life I
don't know obviously there's that very
silly but very emotional goal of buying
the Jets for me that's more fun to chase
than like I almost think I the first
time I might feel actual unhappiness or
weirdness or some sort of version of
like uh might be if if I buy the Jets
like I think about that a lot I'm like
if this happens was this such a romantic
Journey this is not 30 and 40 and 20
year old Gary thinking it's cool to say
this this was 12 year old Gary telling
Robbie turnick and Eric Godfrey I'm
gonna buy this [ __ ] team this has
been like a thing like actually like
forever on that point of those wisdom
years yes one of the things that came
out of my refinement as you call it and
my kind of maybe I meant just at the
start of my wisdom years yes as I look
back on my perspective on exactly what
you've talked about I'm like Hustle and
like my own
um Insane luck of being a very
optimistic person in the worst
situations and I wonder I say Steve
is mindset a privilege and if it is
because you described yourself as being
as happy you've always had this this
drive this motivation is there a risk in
us if mindset if our mindset is a
privilege in trying to advise others
when they don't have the same
privilege couple things one everything's
a privilege yeah
do you see what I mean though like of
course I got really scared I think it's
two years this is incredibly powerful
first of all as a whole separate and
intriguing conversation everything is a
privilege and everything is a
vulnerability and this is like a
incredibly important subject to talk
about I think mental
content is the ultimate privilege yeah I
think the second one is beauty
I'm fascinated that we haven't gotten
yet to attractive privilege
when I look at men and women navigate
this world there's nothing more clear to
me in the privilege that like like
they're like white male I'm like
attractive privilege makes that [ __ ]
look [ __ ] minor leagues if you look
at the beta so let's look at that then
well I'm gonna put I want to go back
because I don't want to lose and I will
lose it because I know how we roll
uh uh I have no interest in thinking
that I'm telling anyone what to do or
giving I do not think that I'm giving
advice I really don't and I don't touch
on this enough and I have touched on it
at times and this is a great format to
touch about I have no belief that I'm
right I have no belief that I'm giving
advice I have no belief that anyone
listening to this should do what I'm
saying I am putting info into the system
and I'm hoping that people can extract
something of value for them based on
their own self-awareness of themselves
most people don't have self-awareness
I'm aware which is why I talk about it
so much yeah but there's a reason I talk
about self-awareness so much why I was a
pillar of my last book why it's a big
character in V friends self-aware hair
self-aware hair
Tortoise and the hair yeah
I think people don't one day when I'm
you know I think 47 year old Gary for
cynics and people that were watching
is better than they thought it would be
than 27 year old Gary right like the hot
takes some I'll never forget when I hit
the scene on Twitter
The Whispers at conferences I could hear
them in the back in the green room and I
definitely read it on Twitter because I
was like popping they're like out of
everyone who's popping on Twitter in
2007 the consensus was the only person
that won't be here in a decade is Gary
because it was too hot too fast too much
people literally I'm empathetic when you
have this kind of energy I'm empathetic
to how this story plays out for
different people I get why the person
burns out I get why the person really
does the ultimate bad thing and
disappears off the I get what that but
that's because I'm not on the extreme
insecurity side I'm on this other side
so I always knew
so but one of the things so I get a lot
of like joy out of like knowing that so
many people didn't think I'd be there
and I'm at the top of it
same way I feel about the friends
nobody has a clue including my inner
circle of how much thoughtfulness I did
in character development this is my
Disney this is my Sesame Street Big Bird
Mickey Mouse right Optimus Prime Pikachu
like self-awareness is profound
the story of The Tortoise and the hair
is profound to every listener of this
there's not a single listener right this
second that's listening here right now
if they're eight or if they're 88 that
isn't extremely vulnerable to the lack
of patience because they're too
ambitious it's the reason they're
listening
so self-aware hair for me is a
phenomenal story I get to tell for the
next 50 years and I can't wait to make
self-aware hair more famous than garyvee
is today because that will be the way I
scale putting positivity into the world
be friends and so I'm excited about that
but back to your point my friend as long
as you come from a place of humility
and understand that ego kills people I
yes we have some luxury of mindset and
communication but for me I don't think
people should listen to me I should I
think people should listen to everything
and try to find positivity and usability
out of everything and they should
dismiss what is clearly negative and
selfish and they should triple down on
everything that is selfless and positive
and that is the answer to your question
that started here what should people do
they should be very very focused on
trying to do the following lean in
dramatically more to things that are
positive your grandfather
podcasts
upworthy.com lean into positivity then
they should be on the awareness Eyes
Wide Open on is this delusional and
lacks practicality like you know if I
just dream it it will happen no
lean in cut out literally when this
podcast is over step back audit your
entire life
from the people you spend time with your
family your friends look at every person
you follow are they triggering your
insecurities for their own self-interest
are they trying to put love into it so
that you go on and do your thing watch
look for it but whatever you do
back to like working out like you know
protein and you know when I when you
know when Mike vacant is like all right
you did a left like protein I'm like
really okay and like during cooking I'm
like wait a minute I'm starting to
finally get some muscles oh because I
was doing protein as [ __ ] after lifts
and not after not lifts I was doing it
right here's something right for
everyone cut out one hour of negativity
add one hour of positivity
if you're listening right now and you're
like uh social's such a drag it's
because you're in a drag mindset and the
Algos and the people you follow are
following you you know what my social
looks like [ __ ] sunshine
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious you know
what my Algos look like [ __ ] sunshine
in the world of the momentum of Darkness
right now sunshine you know why I choose
to fight
for positivity but I refuse to not be
grounded in practicality which is why
I've always thrown curveballs love
everybody it's all awesome [ __ ] eighth
place trophies what Gary what what
eighth place trophies lead to
entitlement and fear of losing and it
[ __ ] up kids
so like it's kind of that juxtaposition
practical positivity is something
everyone needs to add more and so back
to your point we are going to put out
stuff forever because it's how we're
wired the people who are listening right
now for a lot of them they need to
understand where they match with us
and you know you and I match on a lot of
things there's a lot of things we don't
match on the person on the other side
needs to figure that out you I would
argue watching you from afar we know
each other but not that deep we never we
haven't had those six hours that we need
that we will have in the next 50 years
where it starts to get even closer but
even from afar it's clear to me that
you're understanding more and more what
is right from the messages you've heard
and what's not right for you and you
refine it and you refine it
there's a lot to your point there's a I
say it all the time please don't be me
the only thing I want people to be like
me is be as happy as me that's an
insular game that's a self-awareness
game that's a process game that's the
only thing I want people to be like with
me like I'm weird I've got a lot of
weird nuances I do a lot of things that
are not scalable I don't maximize for
I'm always worried when people are like
oh I want to learn how you build your
businesses I'm like it's real different
like you know I don't maximize for
profit I maximize for retention of
relationships if you aren't as confident
as I am when those people leave and
compete with you you become Grudge
oriented and envy oriented instead of
happy oriented like I've got some weird
elements that people can't run my
playbook but I couldn't write run other
people's Playbook so pay attention find
what works for you try [ __ ] try it
multiple times Steve said something you
like try it once didn't work Steve's not
an idiot you don't suck try it again on
this the very Crux of all of this is
that key point which is about self
awareness and as I realized that in my
late 20s that self-awareness was really
the key to
um to most things in life and I remember
writing a quote my Instagram which is
still my favorite quote of all time
where I said
um
there's no self-develop um there's no
self-development without self-awareness
you can read as many books as you like
100 but if you can't read yourself
you'll never learn a thing it's why I've
never read a book yeah exactly so like
like to me the only thing I've read is
my feelings so how does how does one
person listening to this now that's been
listening to our content and you know
they really want to be a an entrepreneur
they want to have a big Media Company
whatever it might be
but they don't know they don't have them
like but objectively they don't have
Minerals Well how do they go about
discovering they don't have the minerals
by going in the pool and drowning okay
you know it's not for you and I to judge
because we've been wrong too much yeah
I've been wrong so much it scares the
[ __ ] out of me and I'm gifted with
intuition that when I'm dead I hope they
can test for it because I think I'm all
time and I've been wrong a ton that
makes me believe everyone's wrong
so if you're listening here's a couple
things that are a good call out that may
bring value instead of what I just said
asking what you're in it for is
humongous
yeah but this generation I don't think
they know because people think I know
this first of all you're part of this
generation yeah
that's how I know but you know but I
know too but guess what my generation
this I'm so done with this my generation
didn't know either guess what when I was
22 all my friends wanted to hook up too
all my friends wanted a BMW too and by
the way as somebody who observed people
his whole life the people that were
older me the people that were buying
expensive wine for me when I was 20 and
they were 35 they everybody wants stuff
to communicate to others that they're
winning we've been putting on makeup
since we had [ __ ] clubs hitting each
other like it's what humans do we do
things to communicate
yes why to hide we're hiding
we we used to do it with status right
now we've decided to [ __ ] on each other
our current move to hide is by tearing
each other down that status too I want
to be more I want to be the most leftist
I want to be the most on the right I
want you know of course the problem is
unlike buying a BMW and going into debt
when you're doing this one you're
hurting other people's feelings um
it's one thing when you're hurting your
credit score it's another thing when
you're trying to make someone feel bad
about themselves that's why the acts of
us collectively at 8 billion people
right now is completely and utterly
unacceptable which is why I'm
desperately communicating at the highest
levels about the stuff that I want to
put into the world as a counter to
people's us against them girls versus
boys blacks versus Jews Republicans it's
[ __ ] exhausting
like once people understand there's one
team humans let's let's you can be mad
at elephants you could be mad at Falcons
but like being mad at each other is the
most counterproductive thing and we need
to go into tribes my country my sports
team I understand this because I hate
all the other football teams it's the
only place I get those feelings the way
people feel about Republicans and
Democrats or genders and races or
countries the only place I can touch on
it emotionally is American football my
level of actual disdain towards Patriot
fans is real I feel the rage
the fact that I do that for something
silly that's a form of escapism that's a
couple hours a week to like reset and
like enjoy and Escape like people watch
movies or ski or exercise that's silly
that's football that's silly we're doing
this in real life to each other
and it's it's got to stop and I think
it's it starts with people understanding
if you are [ __ ] on others right now
it's a complete reflection to your own
unhappiness and insecurity I had a kid
come up to me and this is why I was
asking the question is after I did a
tool can he said to me as I knelt down
on stage he said I want to he must have
been 18. I want to be a public speaker
too and I'm like why
why is always the right answer and the
answer you'll get from this generate
this my generation is well I wanna I
wanna change the world Gary yeah of
course and then you go what do you want
to change about it they go I in fact
what I came to learn is they want to be
the type of person that's known for
changing the world aspiration that's
right they saw the audience right and
they want that feeling the money the
fame the accolades the blue check the
followers the fun I understand it's the
problem with all the things I just
mentioned is they're a vulnerability to
your own happiness if it's not balanced
there's not by the way sometimes people
get mad at me in the other direction
like [ __ ] Gary with my [ __ ] face
off I can buy a [ __ ] watch or a car
I'm like of course you can the why
if you like love the [ __ ] like I don't
understand sports cars and the feeling
of going that fast that's not me but I
understand buying rare sports cards and
that's enjoyable if you enjoy that
that's phenomenal when I talk about
materialistic things I talk about makeup
for insecurity if you are burning the
midnight oil you know how people burn
out they're working till two in the
morning to buy the expensive car to use
it to close their insecurity to get the
affirmation from the opposite sex or
their friends that's that that system's
broke it won't work I I I mean I don't
know what to tell you like everyone's
like okay Gary but I'd rather have the
[ __ ] money like this whole like I'd
rather cry in my Ferrari than drive a
Toyota or take the bus you say that
do you really want to be in a mental
place where you're on the borderline of
suicide and you have heavy drug usage
even though you make three million
dollars a year 17 million dollars a year
because you know this now Steve you've
worked very hard and you have the
talents and the luck of the draw and you
put in the execution to now run in
circles where you know what I'm about to
say is ungodly true which is the
following an extraordinary amount of
people that have unlimited resources are
desperately lonely insecure unhappy and
borderline depression suicidal that's
just truth
and so like the thought of me talking in
any other direction when I know that to
be true seems like the least authentic
thing I can do but even when you say
that you must know that for a huge
amount of people including myself we
have to have that hypothesis that those
things will give us some kind of
fulfillment or meaning we have to have
that fail us before we learn the lesson
Gary's words versus the insecurity that
was developed from my mother and my
father on the playground hypothetically
one of them you know when I was seven
years old the kid said I'd never be
nothing then my teeth I'm not talking
about myself the teacher comes in and
says you're an [ __ ] I think I think
that's right on one side of the skill
yeah Gary's words I don't think it's
either of those I think it's the macro
conversation of happiness
I believe if the kids getting picked on
you'll never be nothing
and she or he decides I will be content
at 25. I will have peace of mind
I will smile 89.3 of my life instead of
I'm gonna have a mansion and a super
yacht
I think [ __ ] gets crazy you're
describing neither so you I I at very
young age only only black kid in an
all-white area we're also the poorest
family so we understand the value so we
had all the advantages of adversity
exactly yes in the con on the context I
was in I was the Blackberry in a world
full of iPhones so I had that feeling of
like not enoughness I get it that means
that um as I go off into the world I'm
convinced my subjective evidence is if
you get the material success of this
habit if you get there then you'll be
happy nothing on one Earth what if
you're 17 Heroes on Tick Tock and
YouTube we're talking about something
else
hold on yeah yeah no no this is super
duper important
what if your 17 Heroes
how has everything changed in the world
can I say that much again that might not
be enough because those first 10 years
as you learn your childhood psychology
you're the the problem is in those first
10 years you will have Heroes outside of
your family
what if your seven-year-old you on
YouTube kids
finds a hero or on ESPN app or something
what if what if Messi your hero at seven
in every other interview
spoke about peace of mind living with it
like what if the conversation changed
because the conversation has changed on
Race on gender on religion on status
tulips used to be the most important
thing in your life The King The King do
you understand in America in 1968 in
1971 in
1971 in America if you were an astronaut
or Pilot you were cooler than an athlete
I want everyone to [ __ ] pay it like
this is a big [ __ ] deal this is what
my [ __ ] mission is in 1971 in [ __ ]
America
if you were a astronaut or Pilot you
were more famous than everybody but the
top 10 athletes in America that Joe
Namath was more famous love them but you
know you understand yeah do you
understand
that Joe Namath is actually a great comp
the Jets quarterback that stunned the
world in Super Bowl three became a sex
symbol
and that started to change he was a
celebrity which was different
you and I are affected by
entrepreneurship now being a celebrity
status something that couldn't have even
crossed my mind when I was 18 years old
maybe even 30 your age right now 30. it
was starting to because you have to
understand do you know who was the
biggest entrepreneur when I was your age
Bill Gates the nerdiest [ __ ] looking
person on Earth
it's fun you're properly speaking in the
framework of our society now my argument
is that communication changes Frameworks
and what if we collectively got on this
boat I I want to so here's what I'm
thinking so if if we manage to get
seven-year-olds absorbing content which
I imagine is probably a lot of your plan
with v friends that is empowering that
is creating new evidence in their mind
purple not red or blue yeah right back
from public at purple right like like
competitive clown is a [ __ ]
accountable ant kids is the thing like
if you lost you [ __ ] lost I don't
want to over coddle it yeah yeah but
Gary vaynerchuk's seven-year-old world
yes if his mother was crying on the
kitchen counter every day because of my
you've I mean we started this by talking
about this using Gary vaynerchuk and
Steve yeah and not acknowledging that
there is extraordinary amounts of people
that are bringing joy into the world
that had alcoholic parents yeah
depressed mom and dads bipolar moms and
dads lose it my mother lost her mom at
five and her father ready you know why I
have confidence in this let's talk about
Tamara vaynerchuk not Gary vaynerchuk
Tamara vaynerchuk was born in the Soviet
Union in 1955 about as bad of a [ __ ]
draw as one can get she goes on to get
another tough card it's called her
mother dies at five
she goes on to have an even more insane
card which is her father goes to jail
for basically in this environment right
now this will make sense to people
finally for being Jewish in the Soviet
Union and he went to jail for 10 years
she finds herself a 10 with her mom dad
and her dad in jail for a decade and a
stepmom raising her who's a young kid
doesn't know what the [ __ ] just happened
to her either right
all the family's gone because everyone's
like just [ __ ] up all the Dynamics the
mom's side the dad's side you're
following the story
she goes on to become
the person that built me because she is
me and I am her more importantly these
core positive person for any person in
her life from acquaintance that met her
once to clearly her three children
she exists I'm not saying that any early
experience defines which way you're
going to go and I'm trying to say that
any early experience is going to be good
yeah yeah could any experience from you
between age of zero and ten I could be a
major factor right and I've sat here
with these childhood uh psychologists
and therapists like Abel May who studies
childhood trauma in that first 10 years
of your life if your parents are
constantly I believe in that Crying
by the way just so everybody who's
listening because it might seem the
opposite because I'm kind of going fast
yeah I believe in that comma
there's something I believe in if one
person that lived that cliche life
has gone on to be an incredibly happy
and productive person in now means it's
capable and true I've noticed this in my
guests on this podcast so I'd sit here
with a guest whose father was
um incredibly violent and did domestic
domestic violence on his mother yeah
this person is the kindest person I've
ever met I've sat here with someone
whose father did domestic violence
because of there's a layer between what
happens in their interpretation we
overreact in both directions it's it's
your interpretation and that's what the
childhood psychologist said you couldn't
there's what there's someone's like
having a sunglasses on your eyes Steve
there's nothing else you know that right
yeah 100 there is nothing else on Earth
yeah so the point the point here is
um regarding that person who grows up in
a household where they interpret yes
that money is the most important thing
do they then have to have that belief
fail before they can learn that the
Lamborghini's because for me I just
can't imagine a world where that was so
deep inside me that insecurity and shame
I can't imagine a world where Steve
Bartlett doing a quote on Instagram or
doing a podcast would have been stronger
evidence I'm watching my parents scream
at each other every day my argument is
you don't know you just know the
alternative
and I would argue that
many people like yourself and I know
weird things because we get unlimited
DMS and emails and you know this about
me because this is where I'm a little
weird
I took a six hour flight yesterday and
read a gadrillion DMs I think what I do
that's a hair different than a lot of my
contemporaries is I'm in the dirt heavy
like I really still see extraordinary
levels of value of being in the trenches
reading those DMS replying to those DMs
like long after I mean I'm watching
people get 10 000 followers and think
there's somebody and get an assistant to
reply like I'm still in it
and in that I see it I I've there's a
reason that people that were deeply
alcoholic have been able to be sober the
rest of their lives after going through
a process there's a reason that therapy
is profound there is a reason that
meditation is profound there's a reason
that exercise is profound to me
everything you just said Is Right
but it is the cliche you get a hand and
then you gotta play it and as someone
who's not good at poker and has won many
hands with three seven off suit because
I'm just a [ __ ] like that I believe in
that in life too there's every version
do I believe that to your point I
believe more than anything that those
first 10 years there's so much going on
it's insane including the environment
you're in right yours was one mine was
one but do I believe that if you then
decide like many do well I got [ __ ]
I got [ __ ] well then if you've decided
back to perspective being everything if
you've decided I got [ __ ] well then
the game's over anyway
what the [ __ ] are we doing here
if if you've decided I can't
because I was unlucky my mom this my dad
this my country this my gender that my
income level this well that's over it
doesn't matter what I think you think
anyone else thinks it's over I just
refuse to talk to another human being
and believe that to be true because
there's been billions of examples of the
alternative billion Steve yeah there's
been billions of Alternatives of the
exact opposite I agree with you it's
just that point sometimes I Ponder which
is um you'll meet someone and you think
this guy regardless of what I say to
them or this this woman is going to have
to have their current world view fail
them by the way I believe that about
every person yeah I don't believe a
single person that I've inspired or got
through to now wins they have to taste
everything for themselves yeah you said
you're weird and I sat with Tim Grover
Tim Grover who used to train LeBron and
um MJ
and Kobe
um he said to me that we all have
our Brilliance our greatness and then
often connected to that and responsible
for that is our Dark Side that's the
word he used the thing that
you know
becomes the the Star Wars the difficult
Star Wars what's your dark side
probably my unhealthy
there's a version of me on a competitive
scale that can get dark
I'm incredibly competitive the only
place I feel like I'm dark is when I'm
competing
like it's crazy moments ago a couple
hours ago we did Rock Paper Scissors
tournament with our leadership team as
an exercise
I lost Peter Chun head of platforms the
guy that talks to snap and everything
I quickly thought after I lost in the
first five seconds
should I fire him
of course of course Steve there's a
little ha ha but if I'm being naked and
an authentic and transparent to this
audience
thank God at 47 the wisdom years uh I
used to punch if Dustin Bingham Joe
minakawa Glenn Curtis Eric Rainey
can you guys all stand up and go to
social media and tell everybody the
following truth of what happened anytime
I lost in Madden 94 in a dorm room I
would punch a hole in the wall knowing I
would have to pay a fine with my own
money but I was incapable of dealing
with losing why because I wanted to win
yeah but why uh because it felt better
than losing why
because not because of like the great
place you're going with this path like
it's really funny it's no different to
the
one of the great lessons I I've gotten
so weird that there's a part of me now
that wants me not to buy the Jets more
than by the Jets I've seen this
Evolution because I want to show the
world how pumped I'm gonna be for Sarah
McGee who bought it
and this is a brain [ __ ] but I'm
starting I lived my whole life saying if
I can show kids that you can go from not
being able to afford a [ __ ] Jersey to
buying the whole team I can help
now I'm starting to believe when I show
the grace
and happiness for someone else's
accomplishment at the expense of my
lifelong dream
and teach people that it was that the
great enjoyment to try it
that I could have a bigger impact than
showing that you can do it that's
winning in a different way in a very
different way and that's what happened
with me with winning and losing I was I
wasn't per se trying to
listen again I'm not a robot everyone's
loaded with insecurity I'm insecurity
with girls much more than business like
nobody was scary to me to talk to a
business but Pam Moses in high school
like even though there was a clear
indication that she had interest that
was still like woo whereas I could have
had a meeting with Bill Gates next day
and be like I'll beat you right so we
all have our places right of insecurity
things of that nature but like you know
when you're five like there was just
such a like I love competition and I'd
prefer to win right and I prefer to win
I did not have a relationship with it
from three to four to twelve now I one
thing I loved and I'm watching a lot of
kids now because I have kids growing up
here's where I get interested in
tenacity and self-esteem
I would lose and I liked it
so there's some you want a dark side I
like losing
I might have cried and been pissed and
wanted to do something about it but I
wanted to play again
there was almost this weird enjoyment of
losing more than winning as a matter of
fact I cheered for four teams growing up
as religious as I am about the Jets
the New York Yankees the New York
Rangers the New York Knicks and the New
York Jets
to this day I am so wildly weirded out
by the fact that I love the New York
Rangers and the Yankees as much as I
like the Jets but the Rangers won the
Stanley Cup in 1994 and the Yankees won
the World Series in 1996 and the next
day I stopped following them
for real no [ __ ] I didn't it wasn't
a plan I was 18 years old when the
Rangers won the cup I didn't think of it
as like the thing I wanted to do I
literally woke up that next September
October when the hockey season started
and I didn't want to watch why uh this
is now at 47 I believe it's my addiction
is the process and the game not the
thing and where did that you're clearly
a unique standout person that loves to
win where did that like it was there an
early moment where that was reinforced
that winning is great Gary no as a
matter of fact it was like not even like
talked you know this is why the 80s were
epic and more importantly I'm joking
this is why my mom was that big it
wasn't like she was like you have like
there was no talk of that it was just
pure DNA I'm massively competitive
I like it I like the game My brother has
it my dad has it like we're competitive
I think it manifests in different people
but it wasn't reinforced it just was
like innate
and I really like where I have it now at
47 which is like I've learned how to
deal with the fact that I'm not the best
at everything that's what life taught me
through the years
um but I really like trying I thought
about this yesterday on a random thing I
must have saw something on social my
favorite thing one of my favorite weird
tiny things that I know is going to
resonate with two percent of this
audience but please hit me up because I
want to get to know you
when I'm on a pickup basketball team of
random people like Friends Play pickup
basketball five on five College High
School your buddies get together when
our team gets smoked like 11-3 in the
first game the second that 11th Point
goes in I get so hyped
when you get smoked 11 nothing 11-1 as
you you know I don't you play basketball
at all no we play pick up something I
know football yeah
in basketball and this may resonate in
other sports Cricket if you're listening
in India football around the world
when we get smoked where it's very
obvious to everybody that four of the
five best players are on one team and
that's why the score was eleven to one
everyone's natural inkling is to like
let's reshoot for new teams
mine is this deep excitement to get the
other four people together looking at
everybody's face and say guys
we're [ __ ] like immediately I'm like
we're not [ __ ] shooting for new teams
let's run it back and then huddle and I
look at everybody's [ __ ] eyes I'm
like my friends we're gonna win this
[ __ ] game because we're gonna outwill
them even though they are dramatically
more talented we're gonna out think them
and most importantly we're gonna outwill
them and when that happens Because by
the way 70 it doesn't happen the talent
is just too great and unfortunately we
also found somebody on the other side
who's talented and has will but the
feeling when you know that you are
dramatically inferior and you get a
group together and you out accomplish
them predominantly on will with a mix of
strategy there's something there that
just gets the hairs on the back of my
neck up is winning associated with your
own sense of self-esteem definitely not
one of the things that makes me so happy
is here's a great indication I didn't
know that until probably the last five
years this is the truest statement I
will say on this podcast
my professional success
has no currency with my heart and soul
this is where my life got really [ __ ]
crazy you know you know this you're
going through an introspective moment
clearing your late 20s like it's clear
so this is like fun for me to tell you
I'm like really in the zone I feel like
we're sitting and just like you know
having a drink
when I realized somewhere about five or
six years ago oh [ __ ]
none of my professional accolades net
worth
exits followers Awards even things like
being on the board of Charity water and
pencils like even when I was getting
admiration for like when I realized none
none
of my professional successes make me
think it's a reflection of me or is an
indicator for me or is a barometer of
self-worth it [ __ ] took I was already
flying it took me to the [ __ ]
Stratosphere my entire
self-worth is wrapped up in the middle
of this podcast when I looked at you and
said you know my entire
self-worth is 100 predicated on people
knowing the truth of how I've interacted
with them
what does that matter
I have a deep love for human beings
I love them for example back to being a
little transparent I'm a little weird
with animals
I have a little bit of a level of
resentment towards animals this is
something my inner circle knows
you know we joke I don't hate dogs
I do hate that humans default into
loving dogs with all their heart and
don't do that to each other
you struggle with that I got so damn
lucky Steve
I came out the womb my mom talks about
this a lot
you know who I was in the playground at
three years old when we first moved to
America like immediately running to all
the 80 year olds and schmoozing with
them you're [ __ ] four
you didn't read Malcolm [ __ ] Gladwell
you didn't listen to garyvee you're
[ __ ] four I'm [ __ ] four years old
and I'm going out with my Jessica Shaya
my grandfather Shia and I'm [ __ ]
gabbing it up with the 82 year olds and
like desperately trying to make them
laugh and smile because a lot of them
came from Russia and were sourpussed in
the last stage of their life America was
[ __ ] up when we all got here it was a
real recession in the Carter years
Queens was [ __ ] Queens back then not
like in his net like it was [ __ ] and
like I had a deep need to make these 85
year olds smile for a second because
they weren't smiling the rest of the day
it's who the [ __ ] I am
whenever I've observed you especially in
the pre-pandemic times where you were
flying all over the world and talking in
every corner of the world you were on
some other [ __ ] yeah and I was to
somebody too I remember I lived in New
York but I was traveling 50 weeks a year
yeah but you were on some like other
other [ __ ] I was looking at you thinking
[ __ ] that's the only guy that's at work
in me yeah and I'm thinking this dude
has a family yes I was a single dude
living in a studio apartment and you
know I get that but you were so the
question which I'm sure you've had level
at you and ever again is
what's the cost there there's cost
there's cost to everything but
one thing I did extremely well was
and I still do this well
um is I over communicate things that I
think bring value to people and I don't
communicate things that I don't think
bring value to people or things that are
important to me that can be owned behind
the door instead of in front of the door
so I think people would be really
stunned by how much family time and
personal time I have do you ever regrets
course
what kind of requests do you have
you know
you know there's certain things that I'm
not ready to talk about but I think
people are I'm too public of a figure
that people know there's things that
have happened in my life more recently
and things of that nature so of course I
regrets I've I also have regrets that I
think will really help people which is
that I am ready to talk about which is
no [ __ ]
but I should have went to a couple more
High School parties no [ __ ] I
shouldn't have come home every weekend
when I was in college and worked in the
liquor store I should have did a keg
stand or two here no [ __ ] like I
should have taken more vacations in my
20s with my buddies you know like like I
should have had a little more fun the
truth is I'll tell you why that was all
hard for me to say their micro micro
micro micro micro micro regrets
these are like
yeah they've been like these I have
nothing in my body including some of the
stuff I'm not ready to talk about that's
like [ __ ] you know like I'm in pain over
this
they're just like little micro regrets
and I answer this because I want people
to see a clear picture on the other side
like if this was me and you actually
having a drink the answer might have
been no
the only reason I think I just said yes
is because I think it's important for
people to know like nobody's like I'm
just scared that I'm so happy that it
seems almost like [ __ ] but it's just
kind of true because I always go to the
same place the the I'll give an example
I think real regret is only grounded in
a very small circle of the people you
love
I I really do and I've put the [ __ ]
work in on the family side it's funny
actually that was a really interesting
segue the fact that I can say to you no
because I've put in so much deposits on
the family side
that actually I'll give you a good one
I've got a brewing regret
my best friend in the world is Brandon
warnicky
I met him the first day of freshman year
of high school
within the first six months I'm like
this guy's gonna work with me we did
baseball card shows together I knew I
was going to build my dad's business by
then I wanted him I [ __ ] courted him
to be in that business from sophomore
year on
and he became my partner in crime along
with Bobby shiffrin my second cousin and
my dad and we built Wine Library
lately I've been feeling that we have
not had enough friend time one-on-one
as we start going and starting to see 50
and it's something I really want to work
on I am I asked this for very as if the
cameras weren't here and the microphones
weren't here I I'm earlier I'm 30 years
old yeah and I want to know the advice
from you someone that I consider to be a
mentor and a friend your investor in one
of my companies as well
um
on that as it relates to that family and
that personal piece what I might get
wrong
because I know I don't think I don't
think there's wrong I think somebody
watching me might say you're doing this
wrong I might watch you and say you're
doing this wrong uh I gave some advice
to a friend of mine Ryan Harwood in a
pool in Miami a couple of years ago that
I feel great about I checked in once in
the last three years curious if he was
doing it I'm positive I'm right but I'm
not right
because what's so interesting about
being
we're all unique but I have a sense of
like how I roll the amount of things
that people have observed including my
mom who's the singular person that knows
me best we share 83 percent DNA that's
obviously a subjective number but like
I'm trying to paint a picture of how
similar we are even she is remarkably
and she is the I am so intuitive because
of her but earlier to this podcast when
I'm like I get wrong all the time nobody
has the ability to be more right about
me than my mom and she's wrong about
things she has been wrong she's been
proven wrong and so what that did for me
in the you know I put my mom at the
highest pedestal uh is oh
me judging Dustin or Steve like like I'm
gonna be wrong all the time I know
nothing about them so what you need to
know is yourself
what you need to know is yourself for me
regrets are completely grounded and did
I spend enough time with the people I
love did you
I believe that above me I absolutely
have
that my parents today could go and I
used to be skipping both my parents my
dad lost his dad at 15. I already told
you about my mom I lived in fear you
know actually we didn't get on that that
one that one is something I wish I
popped up 20 minutes ago in this podcast
the fear of my parents dying because
both of them had a parent die at a young
age was a profound currency in my life
in my first 15 years profound
and so I think because I'm on the other
side of it there's such heavy levels of
gratitude that I got to keep them that
I'm like pumped about it and I can tell
you today as a 47 year old man my
parents are young I expect another good
20 years minimum hopefully 30 they're
like in their late 60s right I'm looking
for 30. but if God forbid I won that
game in a way that a lot of people
haven't I like was with my mom all the
time as a kid I was with my dad 15 to 35
all the time I've checked that box I
mentioned Brandon I think about other
people I love like Bobby Schiffer and
others that I don't spend enough time
with and then of course my kids are so
young that I still want to like milk
that in a significant way but I'm
sitting a hell of a lot more pretty I
think than a lot of people because a lot
of people have also gotten into weird
places with the people they love they
fought over money they fought over an
argument they've cut people out of their
lives that they actually love but it was
their own hurt so I'm incredibly at
peace I'd like to do more and I think
all of us do
five years ago when we had a
conversation I asked you what your
biggest fear was and you responded with
with that exact answer which was fear of
losing your parents yes
um
this profound impact that your mother
has had on you has become and my father
by the way yeah we didn't get there yeah
my dad telling me that word is bond yeah
might be the single piece inside of me
that allowed me not to be the bad
version that some people think I am the
first time I've seen you get emotional
recently as it relates to on stage was
that moment where you talked about your
mother and I I was I was going through
I've got these photos here
of you as this young man I was going
through all of these pictures and I was
reading how you've described her
especially in recent years this was the
my favorite picture here of you you and
your in Russia yeah I've never seen you
um get emotional on stage before other
than when you talked about profound
influence she's had on you so if this
were God forbid the last day you had on
Earth to send a message to your mother
what exactly would you say
she just really wanted to be the best
mother because she didn't have one
I would just I say she did it
what did she do
she made me happy
you know
I want to make everybody happy and it's
because I'm aware of that
she did a better job making me happy
than anything I've ever seen about
anybody and anywhere about anything and
I just feel like
if I don't do that given that I was
given the Gift of Gab
if I don't scale that if I don't help
every you know
the biggest thing I could do for her is
scale what she did for me
Gary thank you
um thank you I have to you know I sent
you a voice note on your birthday just
telling you communicating to you the
influence you've had on my life but I've
I'm gonna say at your face you create a
blueprint
um which is an evolving blueprint and I
followed the evolution of that blueprint
as it's become even more centered on
empathy and kindness and how we treat
others clearly that comes from this
wonderful woman here
um so I thank her for creating a son
that's inspired me so much and guided me
there's so much that you've done which
I've literally copied and I think it's
important to say that to you because
sometimes people say it to me I've
copied your blueprint and that blueprint
has changed my life
um the thing I wish for you and
everybody is I'm incredibly aware of
that and the fact that that makes me
happy hmm is the thing I think about
every day because it makes so many of
our contemporaries unhappy
amen I I really wanted to say that your
face well I had the chance we have a
closing tradition on this podcast where
the last guest asks a question for the
next guest
um I like that yeah
um
interesting
I've heard I've heard you talk somewhat
about this before
what do you want
your Tombstone to read about you
he gave more than he took
it's very clear to me it's been there
for a long time in my head
listen I have a lot of dreams and hopes
for myself we need to teach people
that's okay that doesn't make you bad
that makes you awesome
but if you can balance that with also
giving just a little bit more in
whatever that means and for me it's
communication to perspective I'll donate
plenty of money but that's easy a lot of
people do that that are lucky enough to
be good enough at that
um
I gave more than I took I believe in
that
you've certainly given me much more than
you've ever taken so thank you for that
guy I appreciate you and it's an honest
to spend some time with you thank you my
friend
thank you